how are you Brent I am great rich how're
you guys doing we're gonna be talking to
you again Mike it is great to be talking
to you too what's it like for you to be
calling games on the radio for the
Raiders
in 2010 a great experience brick up
really and I've enjoyed it more than I
even expected to obviously I'm blessed
with the veteran Lincoln Kennedy as a
offensive lineman and a Pro Bowl or with
the Raiders after he was drafted in the
first round by Atlanta I covered him
when he played for the Washington
Huskies and it's been great to be around
someone who when we started the season
was so much more familiar with the
Raider personnel
certain things I had forgotten about the
league is the eternal manpower so you
know back in the preseason doing those
games I laughed and told people listen
they say that some of these players
don't beat preseason but I certainly did
and I'll tell ya it the the game the
field is even smaller and what I mean by
that is that the athletes today you gave
a run down there at the NFL today the
athletes today are bigger and faster the
windows are narrower for the
quarterbacks
it much tougher physically just as the
NBA just as Major League Baseball humans
have advanced but but I must say and
being around John he's a good friend of
mine and wish the coach will he's been
terrific as it offensive coordinator
everybody knows they've had some
defensive deficiencies that they're
gonna try to get over and it was too bad
that they had to let Khalil Mack go it's
simply a matter of economics with the
Raiders and everybody in the
organization told me that he was a
terrific young story to get the chance
to cover him one-on-one because I was
never around the Buffalo College games
and everybody in the organization wishes
him well he's off to a terrific start
with the Chicago Bears but to get back
to your question I have enjoyed every
snap I have to tell you it's it's
energized an old man if you know what I
mean oh you know Brant it's just like I
said
it's it's where you should be if that's
where you want to be and I I did about
seven years of NFL Total Access next to
Lincoln Kennedy he's one he's just a
great human and and and a perfect
partner and I'm thrilled to hear that
you're you're enjoying it more than you
than you thought
now as for Khalil Mack you know the
general sense is that there's got to be
some guys in that locker room certainly
after an O and two starts certainly
after hearing Gruden over and over say
we got to figure out where pass-rush is
that the guys in the locker room are are
upset or can't get over the fact that
Mack had to go as you as you put it what
what can you tell us about the truth or
or non truth of that belief well I'm
sure that some of the players are
puzzled whenever John says that we've
got to have more of a pass rush but it's
a profession and these guys have got
their own jobs to worry about I don't
see any disruption because of it I think
that then everybody although
disappointed
the Khalil is not going to be there with
them anymore I think the athletes from
my observation have moved forward now
after you lose a tough game like they
did in Denver and they're off with their
private groups or with their families or
their friends you know obviously they're
going to raise the issue we probably
could have won the game they weren't
going to beat the Rams either a Clio
Macaluso the Rams are definitely one of
the teams that if they stay healthy
could make it to the to the Super Bowl
but these guys are professionals the
medium lingers on the story because
that's what we do and that's part of our
job that creates interest you know it
would the one of the things that I like
about it a lot which is that we have
quit talking about politics around the
NFL and now we are talking about why did
they get rid of this player and who do
you play next and things like that these
are good football controversies this is
where the league belongs and I applaud
them for that I think they're off to a
terrific start this year I think things
like fits magic and Tampa Bay you can't
create a better story than have a
having this youngster who's out of
Harvard been around the league a long
time when I looked at his stats
yesterday and saw that he had completed
more than 78% of his passes and was
averaging 13 points 1/3 yards an attempt
I said you've got to be kidding me
this is indeed magic so so listen
athletes move on this is a job this is a
profession this is how they make a
living for themselves and their family
they don't sit around and talk about
these things as much as we do no I I
hear you son I'm left to ask a question
but I will anyway Mark Geragos the the
attorney for Colin Kaepernick was saying
on TMZ I can't believe I'm saying these
words but it's true that it's possible
that Kaepernick gets signed in the next
week and he said I'll say this if Al
Davis was still alive and then left his
comment to be glean that it's maybe the
writers could be interested in him have
you heard anything on that front I don't
I have heard absolutely nothing but it
wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me I think
a couple of things are encouraging in
that regard and that's the fact that the
Nike stock hit at all-time high after
the the somewhat controversial ad listen
I thought Kaepernick did good voiceover
I thought it was safe you know I was
fascinated you can watch it to me too
I agree with you I agree with you but
it's anyway though is that I know I said
also at the top that Gruden's like he's
notoriously unhappy with his quarterback
room it seems in and year out I mean as
we know he swapped it he swapped out
everybody that was underneath Derek Carr
under the depth chart at the eve of the
season and and you know it's just
interesting seeing Jon back in the mix
and that might be something that he's
trying to tinker with and seeing if
Kaepernick might be a fit there don't
know yeah you know we will see what what
john thinks going forward derek was you
know he was no better than one of the
average quarterbacks in Game one but
again I go back to that ran defensive
the second half was pretty good and last
week against Denver he was excellent and
as long as they keep him upright and
healthy and that's true any other
quarterback India in the NFL but I
certainly certainly know any Mark Davis
by the way I think I have
but you have to move on from Al to mark
okay okay mark would not be opposed to
having Kaepernick come into that team if
that's what if that's what john thinks
could could improve the football team
and it comes down to that to tell you
the truth but in terms of that I have to
tell you I have not had any discussion
with anybody including John about the
possibility of signing a Cabernet Brent
Musburger here on the Rich Eisen show
are the Rams now the odds-on favorite
there no and yes yeah yeah yeah because
simply because the Patriots have taken a
step back
obviously the Patriots were the favorite
here rich simply because the feeling
among the bookmakers is that the AFC is
a little weaker doesn't have the depth
of the NFC but with the Patriots losing
they weren't ready to push the Jaguars
to the top even though I believe the
Jaguars are a legitimate contender
especially they keep fournette healthy I
was around him a lot at LSU when he gets
nicked up from time to time he's awfully
good when he's uh when he's ready to go
but the Rams would be the favorite right
now they'll wait and see what the
Vikings are gonna come up with the
kicking game and their and their third
receiver they will be up there on the
top five also all eyes on on Rodgers and
the injured knee with the Green Bay
Packers tonight of course a game on the
NFL Network as you know sir I honestly
think the Cleveland Browns are gonna
break through and win tonight I can't
believe I'm saying their favorite for
the first time and you know here at the
big Super contest where those of us who
are in it we picked five games a week
against the spread over the West Gate
and if you go in on a Thursday night
game and the Browns are favorite for the
first time since 2015 I believe it is
they're favored by a field goal I put
them in as one of my entries so I had to
get I had to get all five of my picks in
last night but I can't remember picking
the Browns at all last year and I think
that defense is ready to go that
coordinator is going to be
he's going to be so tough for Sam Donald
I feel for him tonight because there is
nobody nobody who likes to blitz more
than the Cleveland defensive staff and
they're coming after the youngster
tonight
and I also I do want to applaud Hugh
Jackson you know I'm not a huge fan of
that one loss record yep but I happen to
agree with keeping Baker Mayfield on the
sidelines I know a lot of people listen
if you look around the league at the
very creme de la creme if you look at
Brady and you look at Rogers neither of
them were pushed in and made to play
their rookie seasons I still think
having come off the college beat I will
tell you that this game is so much
fiercer so much tougher than what any of
these youngsters faced in college I
believe that every rookie quarterback
even if he's the first player selected
should be on that sideline for at least
one year watching observing and learning
and I just think it's going to be really
tough for Donald tonight against that
Browns defense yeah on a short week two
against Greg Williams who as you pointed
out in a very nice way as all kinds of
crazy you know and he's and and you know
interesting enough we had Trent Dilfer
Brent on earlier this week and he he
believes that Patrick mahomes would not
have thrown ten touchdowns over the
first two weeks for the first
quarterback to ever do that in history
of the NFL if he wasn't sitting behind
Alec Smith and watching for 15 starts
last year I totally agree totally agree
with that you know and so you know it's
interesting so who are your our mandated
ask who are your other four teams that
you think are gonna win this week Bret
Musburger well let me let me go to the
one that might surprise listen there are
a few stadiums around the NFL that have
a college environment and that's where
the crowds I think do help one of them
certainly is up in the northwest in
Seattle and the Seahawks are a lethal at
home in the month of September if you go
back and look at the records they're
lethal in their home opener they're
giving only two points to the Cowboys so
I'm all in on the Seahawks another
stadium where I have been and when Dick
Vermeil was a head coach I went in and
watched several times and the Chiefs
crowd will be electric in there Patrick
mahomes as you mentioned off to such a
great start ten
touchdown passes to games giving
six-and-a-half to San Francisco I'm all
in on that game too going going with the
Chiefs I also I'm going to go back on
the Jaguars hate to give nine and a half
but in watching the NFL Network
I don't think Mariota is going to be
able to go when I watched him try to
throw a couple of passes he had some
clips from practice I don't think he's
anywhere close to 100% and the Jaguars
won't fall asleep earlier like like
Houston did in Nashville lastly and then
I'm going to be a homer I'm gonna be a
homer and my fifth team was the waders
okay they're catching sweet full admit
it I have a bias factor
but I think in this one I'm gonna catch
the Dolphins Pekin ahead they have to be
pretty satisfied about being two and oh
and next week they play the New England
Patriots a divisional game and more than
anything else
that dolphin fans want to beat the
Patriots I lived in South Florida a long
time I know and I know what that's like
they beat him at home last year and I
think that the Raiders have a chance
have a chance here to sneak up on them
is the first time you covered a game in
South Florida NFL game in South Florida
the time you heard Namath you set you
sat with him poolside when he made the
guarantee for Super Bowl three front you
know it's a very good question it it
could have been the first first game
first time I was wounded and what
memories there you know the day before
two days when that famous picture is
taken if you can imagine journalists
being able to walk back to the pool and
there's your Super Bowl quarterback and
you and you're back there with an
informal conversation with him
I had Joe Joe so we're pretty close to
me in the Jupiter Florida area and I had
him autograph I think it might be the
only time that I've asked an athlete to
autograph a picture anything for me and
and he did he's such a good guy down
there and he anytime youngsters or even
oldsters come up to him and ask for an
autograph he's so patient rich and death
and such a good guy but that's a game
all never forget because I was
I was not a broadcasting well I did work
for a radio station along with a
newspaperman in Chicago and I stood next
to Howard Cosell on the photo deck and
Howard was a long time I will tell you
Joe Willie Namath is going to win this
young man that Colts are choking they
Colts are choking Joe Willie Namath will
win I'll never forget that whole weekend
he was right though wasn't he yes he was
he was on top of it and also a lot of
made of Namath clearing it seemed when
and back in those days even though
Namath had the highest salary at the
time they weren't independently wealthy
two players so when a Country Club
I Wednesday or Tuesday I remember which
night it was invited Joe to come out and
receive an honor and give a little talk
to the crowd my wife and I I went out
because I wasn't making much money so
free meals a free meal and Joe got up
and made to guarantee but today they
think it was kind of a brash boastful
way and it was more matter-of-fact
delivery on the part of Joe that night I
was with Dave Anderson the great columns
from the New York Times yes we both
filed stories after that and he just
kind of threw it out you know I I Garin
I care until just kept on going with a
conversation and some newspaperman and
the wife didn't even pick it up till
about 24 hours later so it it now has
been built in this big thing about I
guarantee it and it wasn't quite like
that but but it was a delight watching
what the what they were able to do the
backfield for Webb you back that day or
Dale Bracy was a defensive end to the
Colts and actually they they blocked him
into retirement after that game they did
a terrific job well speaking of a
delight I'm this chat is exactly that
thanks for calling and Brent enjoy the
trip back down to South Florida work the
game and let's chat again real soon we
will thanks reg have a great weekend you
bet that's Brent Musburger at Brent
Musburger on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience